the next section is on the augmented
lagrangian method
which basically is an improvement on the
penalty
method specifically it's a method that
has actually all the benefits of the
penalty method
which is to say it kind of works or at
least as a heuristic it works
but it doesn't require that parameter mu
to become infinitely large
before you get a good solution so that's
actually and in practice it also
actually works better
okay so uh as i said uh
drawback of the penalty method is that
mu
uh this this penalty parameter mu k
increases rapidly and it has to get big
to drive g of x to zero um and what
happens is when you do that the
non-linear least squares sub problem
becomes harder to solve um and then it
says that
you know for we observe that for very
large mu k bloomberg mark mark can
either take a large number of iterations
or fail
uh by fail it just means it's a
practical matter it just takes too long
and and just doesn't work
so to correct that we're going to show a
method that is actually
i'm actually just a minor modification
of the penalty method
um that keeps a different keeps another
uh vector
around um and updates it in a different
way and and it actually doesn't suffer
from that
um that that drawback of the penalty
method
so here's what it is um it's this
the so-called and this is pretty
standard optimization stuff
you may see this in your later
studies you might not too
but it is standard in in optimization so
the so-called augmented
lagrangian is this
um it is going to be the
original lagrangian plus mu
times g of x squared now
that's equal to norm f of x squared plus
g of x transpose z
this is the lagrange multiplier term and
that's another term
and you might even say it's gratuitous
this other term
i'll tell you why because if you're
feasible g of x is zero
so like this thing is zero so um
you could think of the augmented
lagrangian as the lagrangian
of this this is an equivalent problem to
the original problem right the original
problem doesn't have this term
but it's a bit silly because anything
feasible for the original problem
this term goes away so what that says is
this problem is equivalent to the
original problem
i mean it's got the same set of
minimizers if if if x is a solution of
this one it's a solution of the other
one if it's a solution of this one it's
the solution of the other one so
it it just goes back and forth now you
might add like why would you do this and
how would adding this extra term help um
shockingly it does
oh i should say that um
this is the when you say augmenting the
lagrangian
this is the lagrangian and that's the
augmented term
okay um now when you minimize
the uh well okay first we're going to
look at some equivalent expressions
for the augmented lagrangian right so
this is what it is right that's that
augmenting term which seems like a silly
term because that term is 0 for any
feasible point
so what we can do though is actually
move some stuff i mean you see a norm g
of x
you know squared here and so on and we
can simply move some stuff
in and out um and here's what we're
going to do
it's equal to we're going to actually
rewrite this this way if you just simply
expand
this and then you're going to get this
plus that you can just verify by
expanding the norm squared
but this says that this augmented
lagrangian is going to look like this
it's actually going to look like the
norm squared it's going to look like a
non-linear least squares objective
that's this first part and then minus
a weird term that depends on z okay
now let me make a couple of comments oh
first of all it reduces
absolutely correctly to the to the
non-linear uh to the penalty method
right when i take z equals zero this
just reduces to the penalty method i
think you see that
um because that's zero and over here
this is just the it's it's actually it's
it's the stacked
uh norm squared expression for the
objective
um now i can minimize
uh if i fix mu and z i can minimize this
lagrangian
over x well because i just minimized
this and notice it's
very close to what we were doing for the
penalty method there's only this one
little extra term right so this is this
little magic term
that we're going to add to the second
component it's the component
uh that corresponds to feasibility and
instead of just
making this zero we're gonna have this
very cleverly chosen thing
uh here now i haven't said what z is yet
but we're gonna
we're gonna decide what z should be
shortly
so that we're going to figure out from
the optimality conditions
so um the minimizer of the augmented
lagrangian so if in other words if i
minimize
this thing any or a solution of this
right this thing if i minimize that over
x the
[Music]
optimality condition for that is that is
this
is if you work it out it's exactly this
it's dg
2 times the derivative of f at x
transpose f of x and so on and here you
get the 2 mu
g plus z equals 0. so what we're going
to do is we're going to
define z tilde to be z plus 2 mu g
of x tilde then we can write this big
thing up here as this
wow that's awesome because that is
actually this first equation
okay and what that shows is that we have
a similar thing with this augmented
lagrangian
um as we do with the penalty method in
other words
that with this choice of z here it is
z tilde uh it says that that the first
condition that we need for optimality
just holds automatically
and it's only the second it's just
feasibility we need so once you're
close enough to feasible you quit okay
and what this says is that if if g
of x tilde is not small it suggests that
z tilde is a very good update
that's this one for z and that's that
actually describes the augmented
lagrangian method
so here's the way it works um you set
the next x to be the approximate
minimizer of
this expression now that that actually
is minimizing
the augmented lagrangian so the first
step is you simply minimize the
augmented
lagrangian oh with the previous value
of zk um and you used ludenberg
marquardt starting from the initial
point xk
now you do a multiplier update and you
simply use this formula right here
right so and that multiplier update that
this one is the one that guarantees that
along
as this algorithm runs the first
optimality condition of the two
just always holds um then
we do a para a penalty a parameter
update now in the uh penalty method
what you do is you increase mu every
single time you have to increase mu
otherwise you're not going to drive g to
be zero
here though you don't if
for example uh the the this is a measure
of how feasible you are
i should say how infeasible you are
right so this says
if you have made substantial progress in
making it less feasible
um you uh you just keep the current mu
it's fine okay if that's not the case if
you haven't made substantial progress
substantial progress we arbitrarily
defined it to be
dividing the the infeasibility resi
the residual by a factor of four if you
don't then you crank up mu
uh but notice that you have this thing
right that if uh
that that's that's there that you don't
increase it if if you've
if you've automatically made progress
towards uh driving the residual to zero
um so the idea here is that mu is
increased only when needed
and therefore it's more slow than in the
penalty method
and you simply continue until g of xk
is uh sufficiently small that's that is
the method um
okay so let's see how it works on that
same example as we looked at before
um so here what happens is is actually
pretty amazing
on the first step we start with mu
equals one z1 equals zero
we get this point it turned out um we
did not make
prog enough progress so we bump mu to
two
um and then we get this point um
well uh on the next one uh that also did
not make sufficient progress sufficient
progress
meant that we the norm of g was reduced
by a factor of four and
that was just a choice that we made um
so here
now it uh after it goes to four
you calculate something and you can see
right now on the third step
you're you're very close to feasible
so at that point you're close enough to
feasible that in fact you keep mu at
four
and you do just a couple more iterations
and you've really got
a very good solution here in i guess
this is uh
six steps so so this appears appears at
least on this baby example to
work better than the so-called penalty
method okay
and so now this looks like this
it uh it takes us down to ten to the
minus four
uh pretty quickly again these are the
two components of of this
after the first step uh which also takes
like 50 odd
iterations um the the sec the second
the first the first optimality condition
is satisfied and then we just wait for
feasibility it looks like that
um here's what's very cool is if you
look at the penalty parameter
um the other one went up to ten thousand
um
here it goes up to four and stops um
so that is actually the idea behind the
augmented lagrangian
yeah um oh i should say that um
you know there's whole courses on on on
solving
you know so-called non-linear
optimization problems
and maybe you'll take one maybe you
won't
the truth is most most normal people do
not need to know the details of all
these algorithms
most normal people access these by
software packages that
implement things like levenberg
marquardt or other algorithms
still it's good for you to know uh it's
good for you to know like what's inside
some of these packages
and these are not so bad that you
couldn't you couldn't write them
yourself
i mean these are these are pretty
straightforward
we're going to finish with uh one
example
um just to show what it is and it is a
simple model
of a car um and so it's uh what we're
gonna do is
so let me let me give the model so um
the model is here's a picture of the car
uh in in
i guess in in blue uh uh schematic
here and you can see here the steering
angle
that's theta so sorry that's not theta
theta is the orientation of
the vehicle right so what we'll do is
we'll say
p is the position say of the center of
the car um
s t is the speed of the vehicle um
that's the speed uh and then 5t is the
steering angle the steering angle is
defined as the angle of the front wheels
compared to the orientation of the car
so that's that's illustrated here
and the orientation of the car is the
angle of the car
relative to i would say horizontal but
cars don't drive up and down so
whatever we decided to this axis to be
maybe that's a do
let's say that's due east or something
right so it's the
number of degrees north uh compared to a
due east heading
okay so and here's the model um and it's
usually given in a
in a continuous time uh in you know
continuous time way to say it
and it's this uh let's see if we can
even try to figure this out so
um so dp1 means how far does the car go
in in sort of in this direction uh
what's its speed and that's going to be
its speed which is a scalar a positive
scalar
which is s of t sorry doesn't have to be
positive s can be negative
that corresponds to the car uh backing
up so s can be negative my apologies
okay times cosine theta of t make that
makes sense
dp2 dt is s of t the speed times sine
theta of t
theta is the is the vehicle orientation
and then you have this one uh d theta dt
that is the change in orientation is
equal to
s of t that's the speed
divided by l l is the length of the
wheelbase
times the tangent of phi of t so tangent
of the steering
angle okay uh this has got a name
i think this is called the dubenz model
of a car
uh but don't don't quote me on that it
doesn't matter it's a very simple uh
model of car
motion okay and what we'll do is we'll
look at a problem where your job
is to choose the speed and steering
angle as a function of time
okay so we're going to discretize it
um and we'll do that by taking a small
time interval h and we'll simply say
that the new position is the current
position plus h
times the velocity or the derivative
at the previous time step and so this is
very common
um this simple discretization method is
called
uh so-called forward euler euler after
the famous mathematician euler
if you take a course on differential
equations and numerical
treatment of them you'll find out that
this is an incredibly unsophisticated
discretization and there are way better
ones nevertheless this one is just fine
it's just
and it's the one that's kind of the most
obvious
so we'll define an input vector u
it's going to have two components um but
at each time step
and it's gonna be s of kh the speed uh
and the steering angle
and we'll make a state vector we'll call
that x k
it's going to be your two positions and
your orientation so
that's the state of the car and then the
discretized model looks like this
xk plus one the new state is f of xk uk
and
f of x k u k is this uh
this function uh here that's a
complicated function from r three to r
three
um well actually sorry x k is r three
it's actually from
r five to r three because that's three
vectors and that's two
so this tells you how your next position
and your next orientation depends
on how you set the steering angle and
what speed you choose
for at that time
okay now we'll look at a control problem
and the problem is to move the car from
a given initial
uh to a desired final position in
orientation
so um and we also want a small
and slowly varying input sequence right
so we don't want
gigantic speeds and things like that we
also don't want
the the speed or the steering angle to
change abruptly so we want that smooth
and so we'll make this a constrained
non-linear least squares problem
we're going to minimize the sum of the
norms of u squared
plus gamma times a smoothness constraint
on on
on you this is a actually this is nice
that's uh
that's this thing is completely that
that is at least linear least squares or
something like that
um and now we have the constraints which
are not linear
and they are we
we insist uh that uh the final
state uh that the final one has to equal
this thing
and we would have uh here
f of this says this is the state
equation
right this says that x k plus 1 is f of
x k u
k and here uh we're starting
from uh this
doesn't look right this should say that
the initial the initial state
should be x init right that's i suspect
what that is supposed to say
so that should be x init
equals um and then x
one um i suspect i'm not quite sure what
that is
okay so if we run the augmented
lagrangian method
um it actually comes up with a with with
a um
with a trajectory um and it's a pretty
sophisticated uh
trajectory um and here we're given
we're giving you various things i think
in all of these
the initial state um
is maybe zero or maybe maybe that was
this
0 and u1 i'm not sure what that's about
but
here x1 perhaps the initial state is
is is just here starting from zero
okay so here see if we can figure that
out yeah so it looks like you start here
right and then this is getting you you
have to get over to
get over to here and you do right
because the final state is
0 1 0 and that means that your
your uh orientation is still
is still the same it's zero it's looking
due east
and your position goes from zero zero to
zero
one which is right here i'm pretty sure
by the way this involves backing up
we'll we'll check if that's the case in
this one um here's for another final
condition
this is where you're here you start here
pointing that direction
and what you want to do is you want to
be up here you want to be up at the same
position but you want to be pointed due
north
um and that will be this one and that
one and that one you take you take off
driving well in in forward not reverse
and you simply go up up to there and you
do that
here's a crazy one if i say x final is
0.5
and 0 it means you want to be here and
the trajectory found is actually kind of
cool what it does is it goes
back it goes in reverse it backs up
slows down
stops then comes out in forward
uh and ends up where it's supposed to be
so that's a pretty
fancy driving maneuver if you don't mind
by saying so and it's kind of crazy that
this
just running the augmented lagrangian
thing finds that um
here's another one where uh you start
here
and you want to end up at the point
point five point five and minus pi
over two and so that means uh pointed
down
this way and so the way you do that is
you drive forward
here you stop and then you simply back
up along here
so these are pretty crazy trajectories
right um
so by the way i should add that um
people do find trajectories for cars um
some you know this way or ways that look
like this
um so this is done for you know sort of
self-driving cars
auto parking all sorts of other crazy
stuff they do something that's
equivalent to this
it's actually probably pretty close to
just this
so here are the inputs for these four we
can take one and try to figure it out um
let's let's take this last one here so
this says that over your 50 steps or so
you start with a some speed kind of keep
up that speed and then sort of in the
middle
the speed goes down to zero and then
negative speed means you've gone into
reverse
and so on and then the steering angle
should look like this it's zero
then you you turn hard to the i suppose
that's the right
um you would turn the steering wheel to
the right hardest here
then right at that point when you when
you go through zero velocity your
steering wheel is straight then you turn
it the other way to the left
and that's this thing and let's see if
that kind of makes sense for this one
and i think it does because what it is
is you drive
you drive straight here you slow down
you stop there
so you've turned the wheel to the right
now right at the end
your wheel is straight it's uh it's at
zero
then you start negative speed which
means you back this is backing up
now when you back up here uh you're uh
you're turning the wheel
this is to the left in order to back up
and
sure enough that is exactly what happens
here right so
it's pretty cool i mean that that that
just this dumb algorithm can
can uh can find you know pretty
sophisticated um
uh trajectories and maneuvers uh for for
our car
um so it's just to show that the stuff
we put together
it's it's not simple it's not obvious um
i mean if you didn't know any of this
this would be an insuperable
i mean this how would you make a problem
what would you do i didn't even know how
you would do this if someone said
oh make me something that auto parks a
car or something like this
where would you begin and the answer is
this is a pretty important component
of it